all right I'm going to show you a math
card trick it is a genuine maths trick
there's no sleight of hand there's no
youtuber II it is not a sneaky adit or
anything like that is is everything you
see is the whole trick there's nothing
else and also because it is a maths card
trick it will involve a lot of tedious
counting so yeah this is going to work I
have a normal deck of cards they're all
52 cards in there I'm going to look
through what I'm going to do is pick one
of the cards and memorize where it is in
the deck so I'm going to pick one of
these cards and then what I'm going to
do is count how many cards are on top of
it and I'm going to remember both the
card I'm thinking of and the number of
cards above it okay got it got it okay
so I remember I remembering one card in
this deck and I'm bring where it is what
I'm going to do now is I'm going to
broadcast the number of cards in to
Brady's mind right so I'm thinking of a
number of cards I'm going to send that
number into his mind he's going to tell
me that number that he's I've said to
him and then we're going to count off
that many and the next one will be the
card I'm remembering skeptical people
may say you're just going to change your
mind to whatever the card happens to be
so I'm going to write down in fact I
will show how can we do this if you if
you leave if I operate it okay okay if I
take a cold okay so we're going to kick
Brady out he's going to leave the room
but just just just briefly over here
this is my prediction so I'm going to
predict this card here I get that one
there cool and then if I fold this ah
hang on a second
okay you can't see that actually over
I'll put it down there okay okay cool
yep yep you're good you're good so I
wrote it down on a piece of paper I
awkwardly scrunched up with one hand I
put it down there but everyone has seen
the card I'm thinking of so now when I
send this number into your mind right
and you to the number I'm going to count
off that many cards and bam the next one
will be the one that I wrote down that
piece of paper okay you end in case it
goes wrong I was there the right to do
this up to twice at that point we'll
just call it off okay so here we go here
comes the number ready what is it twelve
twelve okay so I'm going to take off
twelve cards the next one will be the
one that I write down here we go ready
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve
okay next card next card is the King of
Spades I did not write down the King of
Spades there's there's not the car
brother down but I'll tell you what
we'll try again we'll try again I will
do one more time so ready okay ready
what's the number here it comes
fifteen fifteen this time okay here we
go fifteen are you right here we go
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen
okay ready here we go did I write down
do I write down the pooris bades
I did not I did not write down the
forest spades what I actually wrote down
was the eight of diamonds and you might
think that this district is a bit of a
bust you tried to guess the number twice
you said twelve the first time you said
fifteen the second time it wasn't either
of those positions it turns out I mean
just putting it giving you one number in
your mind will be slightly impressive
sending you two numbers would be even
better if you changed your mind even
slightly on either of those numbers the
difference wouldn't have been three you
actually had to take three cards off and
there's the next one and again if you
hadn't said twelve and fifteen we
wouldn't have got three are you ready
one two three the next card is the eight
of diamonds now I just look smug for a
while so that's that that that's my
trick where I send numbers into
someone's brain
yeah okay so it's all it's always to be
fair what every time you do the trick
you have to deal it out twice you have
to put it back together each time and
always be it always ins that's being the
difference between the two numbers and
obviously this started off in a very
particular position you know and it was
a position where by dealing it out twice
it always ends up at the difference
there is one slight tweak depending on
if the second number the person says was
bigger or smaller than the first number
and so you have to do something slightly
different in that case but if you get a
pack of cards you have a bit of a play
with it you'll be able to work it out
reasonably quickly
okay if you're still here I'll explain
most of how the trick works and so what
I did when I looked through the cards I
was looking for them and I be honest I
wasn't counting or anything I was just
looking to see what the top card was and
as we know was the age of diamonds so
you look through see what the top card
is that's the card you write down so now
when you start sending numbers into
someone's brain you got to pay attention
to what happens to the top card so Brady
the first number he said was 12 and so
when I start counting 12 the top card
off is the chosen card one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve and when you count cards
off into a pile you're reversing their
order because what was the top cards now
the bottom card of this pile and a lot
of maths magic tricks use the fact that
you reverse cards when you deal them out
so when I put them back together the age
of diamonds will now become the 12th
card from the top in fact whatever
number your volunteer says first it will
end up being that card from the top and
so now Brady picked 15 which was a
bigger number and so as I count to 15
first of all I have to count up to 12 to
get to 15 so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 as
the 12th card comes off that was our
original 8 of diamonds because we've
just reversed 12 again and then you
count 13 14 15 perfect I going to put
three more cards on top to go from 12 to
15 I have to put the difference of the
two numbers on top to go from the first
number to get to the second number I'm
going to put them back together now all
I have to do is take off those three so
I take off the difference one two three
and the next card is our friend the
eight of diamonds again and so no matter
what two numbers they say as long as the
first one's smaller the first time you
deal it puts into that position the
second time you deal reverses it back to
the original order and you put the extra
ones on top once you take those off it's
right there
if you're still watching then you want
to work out what happens when the second
number is smaller than the first number
so I'll show you again so we'll pretend
break did the same thing but he said 15
first and 12 second okay and so there's
the eight of diamonds is still on top so
first of all fifteen okay so one there's
the eight one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen I put it back
on top now the trouble is if the second
numbers smaller you're not going to get
back to the chosen card you just not
going to get far enough but what you
will do is you'll take off well it's a
12 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 and then
obviously you can do the thing with our
no that's not it didn't work boohoo the
trick now is instead of putting these
back on top put them underneath because
now you've had you've put it into the
15th position which is the first big
number you've then taken away that 12 in
fact it's still the difference between
the two numbers with one slight subtle
change instead of taking off that many
cards and then the next one you take off
that many cards as the last one I'll
show you so in this case I would say oh
you pick 15 and 12 the difference is 3
well it's actually the third card here
we go ready 1 2 3 and there it is it's
the 3rd card and so it's still the
difference but all you need to do is
make sure instead of counting off all of
them first and then revealing it you
count them off and turn over the last
one
okay okay what if they picked the same
number twice now if they picked the same
number twice then what you need to do is
I mean obviously you can play off the
fact that they're very very insistent
that that's the number and you say look
okay you seem very insistent I mean in
fact you're right that is the number I
was sending something just went wrong
the first time so I doubted myself but
you know what it probably is that number
then you count them off again and the
important thing is this time you count
off that many cards and then you turn
over the last one you're counting so
I'll show you very quickly so eight was
the top let's say Brady's had 12 the
first time one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve oh no
I got it wrong I'll put them back on
again
and these like no no I insist it's
definitely 12 you go okay well we'll
check maybe it's it's just a 12th card
maybe that's the number I'm trying to
send you one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve oh it
is Wow how about that
it still works oh there you are that's
what you do if there's here the same
number twice here we go here's my
homemade lottery balls I'm going to give
them a little shake and I'm looking away
because I really don't want to cheat
here so looking away got one hand in
there I'm pulling out a ball and it's
number two yes there is one more option
what if they say 1 or 0 at the very very
beginning and if they say 1 or 0 at the
very very beginning this is perfect
right and this has actually happened to
me twice now someone said one top card
and so what you do is you go really the
top card you really think I just put and
they go you know I'm absolutely certain
you go well good I'm glad you're certain
because it is the top card and then then
brain blows up it's absolutely amazing I
think that is that is all the options